what's happening reject nation Greg Alba
here jonald we're gonna watch a video
long one today history of the entire
world education so one of our reward
tiers on patreon whatever video you
request most of the time it's just a
reaction video another reaction video
today comes from a man named Joshua
nevels he's fairly new to our patreon
thanks for becoming a patron oject buddy
this guy Joshua lives all the way out in
Kansas and he wants to go into film
school out in California become an
editor I can't wait to see what you have
in store dude this guy says he's been a
fan of the channel since 2015 so it's
been a long time he said he's been
waiting a couple of years for us to
check this video out I don't remember
ever getting a request for this video
besides you after you joined our patreon
hey man dream come true today we're
realizing two years of anticipation for
you so we're gonna do this for you buddy
love you man it's been great talking to
you over at patreon let's get to it and
by the way guys we do full-length TV
show reactions for many a shows on our
patreon including a weekly Q&A s music
video coverage so check it out over
there let's do this
one two three hi you're on a rock
floating in space
pretty cool huh some of its water ok
actually most of its water I can't even
get better in there without you're
buying them it's sad I'm sad I miss you
a long time ago actually never and also
now nothing is nowhere when never makes
sense right like I said it didn't happen
nothing was never anywhere that's why
it's been everywhere it's been so
everywhere you don't need a where you
don't even need a win that's how every
it gets clever we didn't pause this
right forget this go somewhere do
something I want things to change I want
to invent time in space and I know it's
possible because everything is here and
it probably already happened I just
don't know when to start and that's
exactly where it started
constant I think there's a universe now
what's it made of oryxes in a place
don't like it try a new place at a
different time try to stick together
it's gonna get bigger and emptier but
it's not empty yet it's still very full
and about a trillion degrees great news
the quarks are now how does a type 3
called a proton or a neutron and there's
something else flying around to that
wants to join in but can't because it's
still two protons and neutrons are now
happily married to each other
some of them even doubled up
congratulations the world is now a bunch
of gas in space but it's getting closer
together and it's getting closer
together
oh it's getting closer together [ __ ]
just got to make some brand new man way
crazier [ __ ] which allows newer more
interesting stars to be made and then
die an explosion so now stars have cool
stuff around them like rocks ice and
funny clouds which can accent very
interesting things like this ball of
flaming rocks for example we just got
hit with then another ball of flaming
rocks and it kind of made a mess which
is whether those rocks might have had
water inside them and now there's hot
steam in the sky weather update cooler
temperatures today and the floor is no
longer lava okay
it's raining support flooding alert the
entire world is now an ocean okay what
some things
oh cool like a plant or an animal now a
microscopic speck it lives at the bottom
of the ocean and eats chemical soup
which is being served hot and fresh made
from gnarly space ingredients leftover
from when it was raining rocks or
whatever oh yeah and it can do that it
has secret instructions written inside
itself telling it how to build another
one of itself so that's pretty nifty I
would say tired of living at the bottom
of the ocean using a revolutionary
technique you can convert sunlight into
food it's a sponge
it's a plan it's a worm and some other
types of weird strange water books a
strange fish and stuff but we're still
in the ocean hey can we go on land know
what the Sun is a deadly laser okay
let's go on land nope can't walk it and
there's no food yet so I don't care okay
we maybe have some bugs and fish okay so
okay
learn to use an egg use a stronger egg
and put motor in it if a baby on land in
an egg water is in the egg baby in the
egg in the water and the egg works for
me Wow and now are these huge including
bugs I want to see a map of the land
sure [ __ ] now everything is dead just
getting here the survivors keep your eye
on this one because it's about to become
the dinosaurs here's another map of the
[Music]
it's mammal time here come the mammals
look at those breasts now they're gonna
know that one of them just learned how
to grab stuff and walk know like walk
like that and grab stuff at the same
time and then rocks together to make
pointed rocks ouch it settles on fire
yeah you can make crazy sounds with
their voice finished which can mean
different things almost what you can
walk over here cool well I guess we're
stuck here now let's review there's
people on the planet and they're chasing
their food okay time to plant some grass
look at this I control the food now now
everyone don't want to be my friend and
live near me but don't leave houses
except mine is bigger because I own the
food that's great I wonder if anyone
else is doing this tired of using rocks
for everything use metal its underground
better find was just invented in a sweet
day Valley right in between these two
rivers and the animals are helping yes
and more people who came to buy the food
and I need people to help make the food
and keep track of the sales and now you
need houses for people to live in and
people to make the house that have is
where people and they invent things
which makes things better and more
people coming there's need for many more
people to make are things for people you
notice business money writing laws power
assists
[Music]
are you meanwhile out in the middle of
nowhere the horse is probably being
tamed what is all my Mendelson haha
tired of using lame sad metal
introducing problems made with special
ingredient in from the far lands of tin
land I don't know my dealer won't tell
me where he gets it all so guess what
[Music]
maybe because it's in the middle of the
east not not clop clop it's the people
with the horses and I made an empire and
then everyone owes copied their horses
thanks look there's be the grease for a
beta version of the Greeks let's check
in with the Indus River Valley
Civilization there Khan guess who's not
[Music]
you could make a religion out of this
there's the Bronze Age collapse a little
easier to find thanks look who came back
to Israel it's the 12 tribes of Israel
Charlie you must be DMX the Phoenicians
make some colonies the Greeks copy their
idea and make some colonies the
Phoenicians made a colony so big it
makes colonies here comes the Assyrian
Empire never mind it's the Babylonian
media it's the that's big ah
the Buddha was just enlightened who's
the Buddha this guy who sat under a tree
for so long and he figured out how to
ignore the fact that we're all dying you
can make religion out of this it was
breaking Confucius figuring out how to
have good morals the Greeks just had the
idea of thinking about stuff and just
had the idea of conquering the entire
Persian Empire it's a great idea he was
great and now he's dead hopefully the
rest of the gang will be able to share
the Empire evenly between them
Hakan Chandragupta he says get the hell
out of here will you get the hell out of
here if I give you 500 elephants ok
thanks bye
my mother named Tara at this part that's
the Tamil Kings no one conquers the
Tamil case it will be channel Kanaks
kitchen spell the money and they've got
spaces I'd like to buy the spices me
said the Arabian swiftly buying in him
selling it to the rest of the world hey
China put itself back together again
with good morals as their main
philosophy actually they have three main
philosophies the Greek education levels
of the Greek affine kingdoms
rectification over though my said the
Parthian spice and the Jews high said
the Parthian taking over the entire
place he said the Romans eating the
entire Mediterranean for breakfast
thanks for invading our homeland set the
Jews who were starting to expire dating
their homeland hi everything's great
said some guy who seems to be getting
very funny he was arrested and killed
for being too popular which only makes
it more popular you can't come out of
this from China they just made a
[Music]
new trade routes said idea active
answering the religion to the entire
southeast attendees for an epic trading
Kingdom
there goes Buddhism traveling up the
Silk Road I wonder if we're to reach
China before it collapses again remember
the Persian Empire yep set the Persians
making a new one accent so powerful they
would like to build a long stick as
anyone populated Madagascar yeah let's
do it together across the Sahara Desert
try camels Empire selling lots of gold
[Music]
no actually ok sure said Constantine
moving capital way over here to be
closer to his name don't worry about
Rome it won't fall scooped it first that
Chandra the first a barbarian non Romans
said the Romans being invaded by non
Romans alright just fine but it's not in
Rome anymore so let's give it a new name
oh and here's a huge city population
everyone the go p-- Turks have taken
over the entire Eurasian steppe Rico
Turks those trading kingdoms Korea has
three kingdoms Japan has a kingdom into
the sunrise kingdom so he goes down to
the cuber everyone worships gods and he
tells them their gods are all fake and
everyone got so mad at me had to leave
town and go to a different town you can
make a religion out of this and maybe
conquer the world as well Roman Empire
is long gone but somehow the Pope is
still the Pope
plus there's I wonder if there's room
for Wars here's all the ways that it's
the Baghdad House of Wisdom
just in time for the Islamic Golden Age
let's bring stuff to the coast and sell
him and become the scenario the coast
said the soy healy on the swingley coast
remember this tiny space you have to go
through to get from here to there
someone owns that now want to get
enlightened in the middle of nowhere
the brakes have the biggest Kingdom in
Europe and the Pope is so proud that he
invites the king over for Christmas
surprise you're the new Roman Emperor
said the Pope pretending to still be
part of the Roman Empire
then the freaks broke their Kingdom into
what will later be called France and not
France the northerners are just Norse if
you don't have much time or exploring
they go north north to the northern
north and they find some land two types
of land and they name them accordingly
they also in many names such as Vikings
there's the Roose the Kevin Reese are
they Vikings I don't think so said the
Kevin is okay fair enough the Pope is
ready to make some more emperors of the
Roman Empire
the Holy Roman Empire it's actually
Germany but don't worry about it new
kingdoms time to conquer England said
William it's a birth to play is Turks
set the Byzantine Empire who's getting
so small and almost doesn't exist
anymore
we need help they need help so they call
the Pope hey Pope can you help us get
rid of the seljuqs maybe take back the
Holy Land on the way come on I know you
want to take back the Holy Land yes I do
actually want to do that lets do a
crusade
they did many Crusades some of which
didn't fail but at least the Italians
got some sweet trade deals goodbye
Mayans goodbye Toltecs look at those
mounds
there's the pueblos I was wondering how
to build a town in a cliff guess who's
here come here we're here and pecan is
there Vietnam unconquered itself Korea
just became itself in Japan is so
addicted to art that the military might
have to take over the government China
just invented bombs
and typing and the Mongols just invaded
most of the universe nice going Genghis
I bet that will last a long time some of
the Islamic Turks were unaffected by the
Mongol invasions because they were busy
invading India is it Tonga time I think
it's Tonga time I just found out where
this what Haley gets all that gold
look at this Chad means like there's an
empire there right in the middle of the
the king of Mali is so rich is going on
tour to let everyone know wow that guy's
rich everyone said the Christians are
doing a great job
rhe conquering Iberia which will soon be
called Spain and not Spain please remain
Christian we will check out her to see
if you're still Christian when you least
expect
whoops half of Europe just died China's
back yay hey c'mere time to share new
kingdoms here and there oh look who
controls all the islands it's the
maharajah hop it not Vijaya
maha Paget Vijaya ha oh he's really just
I care a lot about art in the ancient
classics it's kind of like a rebirth
here's a books so you think you can
conquer the Byzantine Empire yep said
the Ottoman Turks nice job Ottoman Turks
oops you missed a spot don't forget to
ban Europe from the Indian spice trade
what that's [ __ ]
Portugal spaceless the world is round
let's go this way to India I feel
America coming through so Chris does his
fame his fame want to hire me to find
India by going around back in the world
no please no please please okay so he
sails into the ocean and discovers more
ocean and then discovers the Indies and
Japan let's draw a line to decide who
gets which half of the world it has
second Inca empires are off to a great
start
I wonder if they know that Europe just
discovered their continent the Hapsburgs
are marrying into so many royal families
they might have to start marrying each
other
move over Lithuania here comes Moscow
Ivan wants to make Russia great again
Rollo tanner it's maybe go invade India
or something
Persia just made Persia Persian again
let's make it the other kind of Islam
the one where we thought the first guy
should have been the other guy it
Christians do you sin now you can buy
your way out of hell that's [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] that's a scam
[ __ ] the church here's Martin Luther in
his new book which might have
accidentally started the Protestant
Reformation
you know what will be magnificent said
Suleiman wearing an onion hat really big
which it is now what a rush it was big
I've been trying not to be terrible
Portugal had a dream that they
controlled the entire Indian Ocean
including the spice trade and then that
dream was real and Spain realized that
this is not India but they pillaged it
anyway damn said England and France we
gotta start pillaging some stuff then
the Dutch Revolt and all the hipsters
moved to Amsterdam damn same chairs we
got to start pillaging some stuff
question one can you get to India
through North America well but at least
there's beaver question to steal the
spice trade that's not a question but
the Dutch stated anyway guess where all
the sugars made in Brazil stolen in the
Caribbean profitable you might forget to
not do slavery the next thing on
Russia's to-do list is to get bigger
Britain and France are having a friendly
discussion about who should control the
entire world
more specifically over weights into a
seven-year discussion giving Prussia a
chance to show Austria who's boss but
what about Britain in France did they
figure out who's boss yes they did
it's Britain guess who's broke also
Britain so they start taxing the hell
out of America [ __ ] you says America
declaring their independence and
fighting for it and France helps them
win now Francis broke and Britain will
have to send their prisoners to a
different continent wait if Francis
brother King and Queen still wear such
fancy dresses
let's overthrew the palace and cut all
their heads off said Robespierre cutting
everybody's head off until someone
eventually got mani-pedis head off he is
starting to lay the idea of a revolution
especially the slaves to free themselves
by killing their masters why didn't we
think of this before
wait who's in charge of France now he
said Napoleon trying to take over Europe
luckily they bashed into an island but
believe a banished them to another
Island there goes Latin America becoming
independent in the Latin American Wars
of Independence
Britain just figured out how to turn
steam into power so now they can make
different types of machine my head nurse
with the shoes
then they invent some trains and conquer
India and maybe put some trains there
hey China Britain my stuff from us now
did we already got everything says China
so Britain tried to get them addicted to
opium which worked actually
but then China made it illegal and
dumped it over to the sea so Britain
threw a hissy fit and made them open up
postings and give them an island Britain
and Russia are playing a game where they
try to stop each other from conquering
Afghanistan also the that's just where
he lives
India just had a revolution and they
would like to govern themselves now
that's it I put on a tour for someone
before keep it I'll repeat it States
finally figured out whether slavery is
good or bad it's better they decide and
then they continued manifesto which is
to kill the rest of the natives and take
them away maybe kick out the Mexicans -
I know
let's rape Africa said Europe scrambling
to see you could rape at the fastest
Britain and France are still hungry wait
Spain controls Cuba Oh blame something
on them and go to war what should we
blame on Spain let's blame the Maine on
Spain so they blame the nade on Spain
now we're in business
zel ready to kick panama out of Panama
and make a canal to oceans Britain just
found oil in the Middle East China is so
tired of being bossed around if they
determine and make a new stronger
government which is accidentally weaker
and controlled by a guy from the
previous government you're a peasant
head of Loris is the last war so they
start World War look at those guns it's
gonna be a great war so great we won't
need a second one after it's over they
bloom Germany Russia went on strike and
workers overthrew the government now
everyone's paycheck is the same come in
soon the Arabs rules and Britain helps
now the Ottoman Empire is gone so we can
give the Jewish people please to
hopefully the arocs won't mind let's cut
the cake said sikes in Toccoa carving up
the remains of the not-so Ottoman
anymore Empire except then the Saudis
conquer Arabia it just seemed like the
right thing to do
hello yes it's the 1920s calling let's
get in the car and drive to a party and
listen to jazz on the radio and go to
the movies the economy is great and
it'll probably be great forever just
kidding he's mad at the Jews for
existing Japan is finally conquering the
East and they're so excited they raped
Nanking way too hard they should
probably just deny him Hitler's out of
control so the international community
tackles him and tries to explain why
killing all the Jews is a bad idea
but he kills himself before they could
explain it to him bonus round Pacific
showdown United States vs Japan seems
legit hi I'm Gandhi and Britain doesn't
get the hell out of India I'm going to
starve myself in public well that worked
bonus now there's Pakistan actually to
Pakistan
one of them can be angry - later the
Jews I only figured out which one of
them should live in the Holy Land
me they both said at the same time as
happy China there's a new China in China
what's on the menu communism no thanks
said the other China
escaping to an island I wonder which one
is the real China there's the Korean
Korea vs. Korea nobody wins then it's
unpolished forever let's meet the
sponsors oh it's the two global
superpowers they're having a friendly
debate over which the system is good and
which one is an evil virus of Satan and
they both have atom bombs wait wait no
that will be the end of the world let's
just keep it cool and spy on each other
instead hey and make sure we have enough
atom bombs I'll race you to space we're
tired of being pillaged so here's a new
map with new countries now you can't
tell who they're being pillaged by the
United States finally decided whether
racism is good or bad it decided it's
bad and the world agrees
South Africa I might need a little to
think about it let's check the world
population hello okay
technology's better - that might keep
happening Sookie relax a little man
accidentally falls upon your oxy Union
oh no I can all use the same money
except Britain because they don't feel
like it let's check them out surprise
it's on the computer
someone just attacked America I bet
they'll remember that phone call
surprise it's in your pocket want to
learn everything surprise it's on the
cover now your phone's a computer which
is in your pocket whoops the economy
just crashed don't worry the big banks
won't fail because they're not supposed
to surprise flying robots to bring some
new friends some people have no food the
globe is warming
[Music]
everybody let's inventor said the thing
inventor inventor after being invented
by a thing inventor that's pretty cool
by the way where the hell are we really
sleepy go back to school I think I think
I got some of it too much history
there's so much history I'm supposed to
spread this out over the course of like
20 years this is too much no there's so
many places and people and Wars and and
advancements and religions and and
enterprises wars
fortunately I got all that down no
problem I was able to retain all that
information I am a sponge like that oh
yeah you're gonna pass the test tomorrow
no problem no problem then no problem no
problem
no problem just rush out I really did
appreciate this video
I mean Joshua did say it's a pretty fast
paced video not prepared for how fast
that video was gonna be that's an
understatement I'm gonna go on record as
this yeah I feel like if you pause this
video every two seconds and took a note
you might learn the world's history I
mean you could learn pretty much
everything here and then just go let me
pinpoint you know that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna break down this
entire video piece by piece riff off of
every single thing that's mentioned here
this video is part of a 300 parts - yes
this videos gonna be exceptionally long
this is really really impressive
it's like and zany and well I haven't
seen a video like this I think maybe
ever or at least in quite some time the
way it's edited is brilliantly done I
love like the mixture of like different
sound effects he uses whenever there's
like a country or something America
[Music]
the strange singing yeah yeah yeah we
could make a religion oh yeah I love
those bids you can make a religion oh
don't
it's funny watching the evolution of the
history of the world because you can
also kind of see it sort of
deteriorating as it gets bigger hmm
simultaneously which is like sad like
this video I thought what my going away
we're like wow it's amazing where we are
now and how far we've come and in so
many ways it really is and then in a lot
of ways you're like kind of made a mess
out of things how a what society came
into play Society came into play games
all about territorial and ownership oh
yeah on curry that's something that
hasn't changed yeah I mean you kind of
missed that in in a school environment
where everything is so protracted and
you're learning this information over so
much time but you see it all crunch
together in a 20 minute package you're
like oh wow one aspect of the history of
human life is just us arguing over where
to live and yeah whose stuff is white
and out of control yeah yeah and then
and also you know to see it accelerated
like that you realize like oh you you
think that some of these squabbles and
some of these issues are very old and
then you realize like no they're just
one in a chain reaction that's keeping
on reacting it's been repetitive one
part music this video is kind of
repetitive and then I realize that's the
history where's the history of the world
that's repair there's a chain here I
think is videos fascinating cuz it
exists in this form almost out of
necessity like if you're gonna make in
any way a digestible non epic length
history the world to have to be kind of
exactly like this so yeah it's kind of
hilarious but it's also like weirdly
affecting by the end because like even
the speed of the video makes you realize
that each little generations impact is
just one in a series of little footnotes
the problem is you can't really catch
much before there's new information but
this was like a great recap like I've
been wanting a way to refresh on world
history it leaves a nice catalyst it's a
big recap on it I don't feel like this
obviously is not the end-all be-all for
your big history lesson because it's a
lot of facts of like all what happen
until service
yeah all the details addresses like like
quick facts you know of like this war
happened this part happened this part
happened but a lot of the why did this
happen is the big detail who was
responsible and yeah yeah exactly what
else was going water by a lot of that's
really missing I think what's cool about
this is you can find a moment or two if
you like please this video really slow
you can find a moment or whatever and go
I want to learn about that part I want
to learn about that part and you could
read into that and learn about it see I
wish they would take this video and make
it a 300 part series just about every
bullet point that would be cool of every
part of what like I'm like the the
breakdown of the breakdown yeah the
visual style of it of how they keep
going around the world it is crazy to
see that when they call it the history
of the world then they're catching up to
modern times we did just start spreading
and spreading and spreading and
spreading and now here we are today and
it's hard to like kind of wrap your mind
around that I think for some like me
it's our iris on a cell mining it oh and
I can't seem to get rid of us every like
month you could update this especially
with the way America's been lately oh
yeah like every every couple years at
least you should just add a minute on
you can like when they were going over
that Russian and like JFK went at that
time yeah oh man Foley this video was
made a couple days ago you would have a
whole new thing added alistun that makes
you realize just how many conflicts are
not fresh yeah as much as people love to
roll her eyes that like history does
just keep meeting and some stuff that we
consider like just common knowledge of
what's right and what's wrong we had to
go through some major things and
obstacles and Wars to learn this is an
okay and America learn racism's bad yeah
things like that where he can say it so
quick and funny because you're like well
yeah it's wrong
slavery's bad yeah we know that but
there's a time where we are we had to
learn you know the hubris of all the
people who are like no no I want to
conquer like all of this land and then
immediately breaks back apart things
like that these weird things that seem
like no brainers that we had to learn
over
are you gonna rule that many people and
how yeah how are you gonna like enslave
people like what is happening I don't
remember the quote from true detective
but there's something Matthew
McConaughey say it says about how
consciousness is like the the evil part
of humanity I think human consciousness
was a tragic misstep in evolution we
became too self-aware nature created an
aspect of nature separate from itself we
are creatures that should not exist by
natural law mmm that sounds god [ __ ]
awful that's like what this made me
think of how the world was just
naturally evolving and then society came
into play and then we kind of it became
this repetition chain of command that
just kept spreading like a virus over
the earth that is I think our
consciousness came into play truthfully
because like that's where you'd start to
develop your need for things like
societies like laws and money and
religion oh yeah it's like I don't have
the same game from us coming up with it
you know and we don't have like the same
pack instincts and stuff the animals do
so after a certain point in time we were
like okay I guess we have to collaborate
on what is gonna be and maybe try and
like agree to stuff and then you know
you got some pockets of people who are
just trying to do that a peaceful way
and they got other pockets people were
like we're gonna agree to stuff in some
of our that's mean we're gonna just take
what you have I mean I'm grateful for
where we are now I mean it ends I'm just
weird like he's talking about true
technology advances but they kind of
feel sci-fi when you're looking at
everything else there so they're on the
tail end you know yeah so I'm very happy
for the time as we live in now I think
like we live in a time of miracles like
here to go back a couple hundred years
ago to tell you about like planes and
stuff would be like that's a that's a
thing of you know myth yeah so it's
pretty amazing to see why or no we still
have a lot of the same group repeat
Society ways you know and we're all just
trying to improve people are people
people are people why should it be that
you and I get together soon so but this
is a video you can definitely watch on
repeat I would torture someone with this
video I wouldn't I would lock them in a
room and just have this on a loop and
before you know it they know the entire
history
for a week and they would know at all
what I would do is put it on a loop but
every time it reaches about three
minutes to the end I'll have another one
start playing so after a while you just
have it overlapping and overlapping and
overlapping and then you really will
lose your mind this was an amazingly
dumb video perfectly executed this must
have taken us guys must be really
surprised that he edited this in just a
day and he improvised all that dialogue
- he went all off memories he didn't
spit or anything it's pretty amazing how
they were able to do that alright guys
well I'm gonna go to bed you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation thanks
Joshua for that insane video why he
waited two years for that I don't know
if that was the response you were
looking for and you could check this out
AAB type my brain hurts stop page
there's a lot of fun stuff there I'll
talk to you guys soon my brain is tired
I don't learn